I'm so happy to be able to talk to you
today [music]
and mashallah my brother our Ali Hammuda
is doing a great job. [music] Work
forever is a very very uh beautiful
cause because the reward of what you
give is not just at the moment of giving
but rather it is prolonged for a very
very long time and it lasts for as long
as that work continues to generate to
generate some form of benefit. [music]
So I highly recommend work for Forever
as an ambassador of Abdullah Aid. I know
the the uh partnership that we have is
amazing and uh not many people
understand the concept of wak yet the
reward is far greater through the wak.
So inshallah if you can support work
forever uh it will be really really
amazing and very very rewarding.
So I come from a siki background and
we're told to research other religions
while staying content in us. And the
question I have is about morality. Uh so
morality the rules that Siki points out
to is it can be universalized. Um treat
every person as an end and forbid
coercion or harm to innocence. So siki
uh in gwani teaches us that human is a
jud divine light and so the body is a
temple and every life you cannot violate
that life cuz it's a temple. So and siki
also promotes the no one is my enemy
idea. So there's no punishment for
apostasy in siki. There is discipline in
service uh no violence. Force is only
for defense of the oppressed. So by
contrast these three ideas in Islam uh
apostasy should be punishable by death
and male male authority over women. So
this just ideas I'm bringing that I've
heard from people that speak about
Islam. Yeah. Whether they are against or
so males have authority over a woman in
the mainstream readings you can say some
uh readings say is permitted to strike a
woman. And then lastly uh so captives
and concubines. It says uh that you can
have sex with the owned slaves which uh
avoids consent. So lastly my question is
a system that protects equal uh
inviability
forbids coercion of belief and rejects
non uh consensual sex is morally higher
than the one that permits them. So given
just these points, how can you believe
that Islam has a higher or moral
superiority than siki belief?
[applause]
So the first point that was mentioned
was killing. Uh can you just say that
first point again about killing
[clears throat] with regards to it being
a universal principle or it can be
universalized?
>> So what was the first point about
morality?
>> About killing?
>> Oh about killing. So that that was about
uh apostasy.
>> No you said there are certain principles
>> that you get from siki that can be
universalized and one example that you
gave was pertaining murder or something
along those lines. Just re just remind
me what that was.
So it says by morality that um it can be
universalized. So that means that
Gurbani teaches us that the body is a
temple and you cannot like um uh violate
that temple. So you cannot go around
killing a person just because of a
right. I've got you. I've got you. So
this is the argument that it's not just
from siki. This is an argument that
comes even from uh atheists as well or
possibly agnostics. So they say that you
know morality it's it's fine. Why do we
need God for morality?
But the principles that you've mentioned
are the principles that are expounded
upon by humanists as well. You might say
that killing somebody is bad. That's it.
But I'm sorry that's not something that
can be universalized. Nor is it
universalized. In fact in this country
you can get one person saying killing is
wrong. However, I guarantee within 1
minute of having a conversation with
said individual, they will retract on
their statement. Why? Because of a
change of definition. I'll give you an
example. Said individual will say
killing is wrong. It's barbaric. It's
bad. However, they will also accept in
that same vein that after 6 months, it's
okay for you to abort a child.
Killing is wrong. But for them, my body,
my choice. So over here, we're seeing
when I was debating or having a
discussion with said individuals, they
said, "No, no, no. It's not a baby, it's
a fetus."
So a shift of word, a shift of
definition now suddenly makes it okay
for you to kill such individual. Let me
present another example. What if killing
an individual
and this is in the moral philosophy if
somebody's studying this it comes under
utilitarianism if killing one individual
will save the lives of a hundred
[clears throat] is it permitted well
most people will say yes but if you go
with that which is more in line with K's
categorical imperative
well in that case no you'd say no but
still you'll end up indirectly killing
numerous other people. So when you say
killing
or harming the body can be
universalized, I beg to differ. I would
say and I would retort with who decides
and what are the metrics. Where are we
getting these metrics from? These
principles that you've said on the face
of it and on the surface of it,
mashallah, fantastic. I'm sure most of
us on the surface of it we would
absolutely agree. But the problem my
brother is it's the specifics that get
us the application that gets us and
that's where the debate lies. That is
utilitarianism correct or is can
categorical imperative correct? Yeah.
Some say morality is subjective.
Well, generally speaking that's how it
seems. Yeah. When it comes to say a
non-Muslim country, non-scripturalbased
country, they will say yes, it's
society. Society, you know, decides and
you know, morality can change 50 years,
100 years. We already know in this
country what the laws for homosexuality
were all but but 100 odd years ago.
Same with LGBT. Laws change. People's
perceptions change. So there's a debate
between subjective morality and
objective morality. Yeah. Where do we
get the specifics from? Where are the
guidelines from? The debate comes down
to scripture. Then the next question is
which scripture? That's where the debate
actually lies. Now you uh you mentioned
a few points. Now I think those few
points are a gross misrepresentation of
what Islam actually is. Yeah. I have to
be honest with you here. When you go to
America, no one's going to say we're
going into a land, land of the free. Or
is education free? No. Is medical free?
No. Am I free to, you know, do this and
do that? Insult some, you know, make
racist comments? No. To harm somebody?
No. So free what? Oh, is is it true
that, you know, if I do this law wrong,
I will be put in the electric chair? Is
it true that if I maybe say something
treason based and I leave the country,
will that be okay? Absolutely no. Yeah.
But that's not the first thing that's
mentioned. Yeah. Why is it, and I'm not
just saying to you, again, I'm
addressing the whole crowd here. Why is
it when it comes to Islam
and Islamic law the when we talk about
Islamic law it's it's about five six
things and they are significantly straw
manned and they are top of the list as
opposed to Muslims being the well it's a
UK statistic it was ironically it was
covered by the Daily Mail and the Daily
Mail was saying that the religious group
the religious group that's known to give
the most charity are Muslims. Well,
that's Sharia law. That that's that's
not at the top of the list. Or let me
give you another one. Gallup pole. Yeah.
They asked people of other faiths and
they said, "Is it ever okay to kill
innocent people with a resounding 78% it
was the highest?" And it was Muslims
that said, "No, under no circumstances
can you do that." Yeah. So if you are
looking even at the statistic of say
happiness why because of praying five
times a day the relationship one has
with one's parents with neighbors that
is also shar law when it comes to
apostasy because that's what you
mentioned and Ali touched upon it
again this is something that needs to be
fleshed out because
and people might be surprised leaving
the religion does not get you killed
shock horror what I thought no if you
are in a Muslim country you leave the
religion that's it like you can go about
your life however
if now you go to the streets you start
corrupting the people yeah because in an
Islamic country the greatest sin is shik
yeah assigning partners with Allah
etc yeah so It's wronging Allah.
Now, when it comes to wronging Allah,
because again, there's scales for
morality here. The scale for morality in
Islam is going against Allah,
disbelieving in Allah. Yeah. Why?
Because if a person dies, they'll go to
hellfire. So there has to be
consequences. There has to be a system
in place over here. So if a person
leaves, they don't do anything. That's
it. They can leave. No issue. They can
practice their religion. Frankly, their
churches, they have their own sections.
They want to drink in a Muslim land,
they're allowed to do so. But when you
go outside and you now want to corrupt
the other Muslims in the land, then it
becomes an issue.
>> Then the highest punishment
is killing the individual. That's there.
Yeah. However, that's not the first
punishment. There have been many cases
in which the person has been imprisoned.
The person has been exiled. Yeah.
They've been there's a treaty with
another country. But apostasy is there.
That doesn't mean that if you leave
that's the prescribed punishment. It's
one of the punishments. But people make
it seem like you've left that's it.
>> Yeah. But that's not the case brother.
Yeah. The other thing that you mentioned
was taking this concept of sex slaves.
Where is it in the Quran? It's not in
the Quran. Yeah. It's actually a concept
that's taken from the Old Testament.
This terminology even in fact say
apostasy as well. Yeah.
We don't have a concept of apostasy.
That's something that's been
superimposed.
Yeah. Edward um say's written that book.
Orientalism. Yeah, it's actually falls
under the guise of orientalism. So even
if you take for example sex slaves,
that's not the concept within Islam that
oh you you just take someone's a slave
that that's it you can now have
intercourse with them.
>> It's a it's a made up it's a made up
word by the way it's a madeup word. Tell
us and not only that for example do you
believe uh you have one of your gurus
which is the book right the guru grand
sah sahib
>> guru grand sahib
>> yeah um you have something there called
if I'm not mistaken it's called daramut.
What's
tum yud? No. So taramyud is what you
fight mentally. So it says uh I can use
examples of uh
>> it's called it's called it means
righteous war.
>> Righteous war within the mind. Yeah.
>> Okay. Good. No not within the mind. For
example, you do realize you carry a
sword or a knife, right?
>> Yes, we do.
>> Okay. Why do you carry that?
>> As I mentioned in the question itself
that um one of the points about siki is
force is only for defense of the
oppressed. No, but it says also a
righteous war. What do you define as a
righteous war?
>> What that that is what we define as a
righteous war is when uh in defense of
the oppressed.
>> Okay. So you would agree and this is a
fact that Sikhs have been oppressed and
been under persecution throughout
history. Right.
>> Is that is that am I correct to see
that? Good. So that's one of the reasons
they carry that and I I don't blame them
at all. Like if you are being under
attack, I call that a righteous war. I
call it righteous war that you are
carrying a weapon because you are
constantly under attack and that is what
um one of your scriptures say that. So
to us that's the same concept.
[clears throat] So you see Islam is
pragmatic. Yeah. And I don't want to
long it too much because we've got a lot
of questions. The brother said want to
keep our answers short. Forgive us. But
the the the thing is this bro we need to
be pragmatic. I can come to you and say
I have a religion called Laala Daisy.
Okay. and LA Daisy, we just love
everybody and I walk here and I throw
flowers and I do back flips and I'm I'm
like a hyp like and it's like okay what
do you do when some like Christians say
this turn the other cheek? Come on, man.
Are you telling me if I slap you, you
don't turn on other cheek? Yeah. Okay.
You're not. Be pragmatic. Be real. It's
We live in the real world and Islam is a
real religion that deals with
pragmatism. Do you get what I'm trying
to say? It deals with real problems,
real solutions. And that's the reason
why if you look and I genuinely believe
this as well, even undermassed
as a righteous war if among the seeks
there is an individual who says, "I am
not a seeki anymore." And you can say,
"Okay, no problem." like I said about
the holy temple, whatever, like the
body. Bye-bye. If he says, "No, no, no.
I'm going to stay here. I'm going to
talk negatively against seeism and I'm
going to and it's going to start off
with words and he's going to start
gathering argument sake a group of
people who are going to attack a
innocent seek woman walking because he
believes seekism is absolutely wrong.
It's brainwashed me for years. I'm an
ex-seek and I'm going to take it out." A
righteous war will be what? You use that
sword against that person who's
attacking that woman and it will be
classed as what? A righteous war. So
we're saying in real scenarios, in real
situations, what Islam is prescribed, it
doesn't sound good to the ear, but it is
a real pragmatic solution. That's the
reason I came to Islam because it's a
real religion. It doesn't deal with like
hunky dory. Yeah, if someone slaps you,
going to give him a flower, send 10
pounds to his account. No. So I would
say my brother that this is where the
righteous war that you have, we have the
same, [cough]
excuse me, we also have righteous war
against those who've been oppressed. If
they're Muslim or non-Muslim, if as
Muslims we see in our lands the Sikhs
are being oppressed and the Muslims done
this when the Christians were being
persecuted, when the Jews were being
persecuted by centuries by the crusaders
and by the way the word infidel comes
from the crusaders. They ascribe it to
us. Apparently we say you're killed
infidel wherever you see them. Yeah.
Okay. So watching horror movies. Yeah.
Okay. So the thing is is that Christians
were p protected by other denominations
that was trying to kill them and the
Muslims would go out to war and at
[clears throat] one instance I can't
remember who the ruler was. They went
out. They couldn't defeat the army. THEY
CAME BACK TO THE Christians and said,
"Here's the Jiza tax that you used to
pay to protect you. We couldn't protect
you. Here's your money back." When Salad
Aubi conquered Jerusalem. Yes. When the
Christians were desecrating the holy
temples of the the Jews, the synagogues
and killing the Jews. Who brought back
Jewish families back to those lands to
live in co? It was the Muslims. So, in a
nutshell, I hope that answer your
question. We are [clears throat] going
to try to answer it fast. Inshallah. If
you do want to after the event, we can
talk as well. Just a quick point on the
uh you said that Sikhs will be protected
under Muslim rule let's say. Yeah. Do
Sikhs classify as demi.
>> Okay. Yes. So for example there's
difference opinion. So there's the
Christians, there's the Jews and there's
also maj um majestim the the
>> the you know the no not politics there
you know the Persians.
Yes. So some of the scholars say even
when it comes to idol worship they can
live as long as they pay the Jiza. So
there is a difference of opinion. Some
say no, some say yes.
Which where do you send
>> me? I'll be honest with you. I haven't
looked into the matter. But I mean I
mean if I'm if I'm the Islamic empire
ruler, if I'm mean I'm I'm I'm looking
after you guys. Inshallah. I'll follow
the opinion.
[applause]